when we are more mindful we get a joy in
a way that the seat of the mindfulness
we all have that we does not to buy that
from somewhere else not necessarily
funding for the Enlightenment or
spiritual reason in a sense but a rather
we believer or non-believer will all
need a peace of mind so the peace of
mind comes from the mindfulness through
that we understand how important
kindness our compassion one mental good
quality lead into the next and the next
and the next
the fundamental what we're talking here
is mindful all the holy beings each
religious leader the first thing out of
devil they all come to say to us be kind
be kind to yourself and be kind to the
other to be kind is the Jesus be kind is
the God be kind
as the Buddha
another thing is very important for us
to practice the patience walking with
somebody or the relationship husband and
wife girlfriend and boyfriend any
relationship lives not perfect live
never be a prophet how much we put into
effort to be perfect is no perfect
everything we are human patient is a
wonderful to have so if that day is
somebody who in your life if he or she
is a so stressful and at that time some
time not necessarily there's not much
room for communicates just be patient
just be truly this is these are not our
religious are training but more as a
human being we all need that kind of
quality but yet again the seeds we all
have them we all have a patience how
much we call an impatient person he or
she has a seeds of the patience and the
kindness and compassion all of these
seeds we don't have to buy anywhere we
have we'll all have a room to grow and
but we all have a seeds or beautiful
kindness and patience
you